la question s'adresse à madame la
ministre la transition écologique et
solidaire
les études scientifiques sur la fonte
des glaciers la disparition des espèces
ne se comptent plus tant elles sont
nombreuses les préoccupations des
français notamment les plus jeunes sur
l'état de notre environnement et
l'urgence climatique sont de plus en
plus importante
les citoyens attendent une forte
mobilisation des politiques pour nous
adapter au changement climatique et
préserver notre biodiversité
sur le terrain les collectivités locales
en ont pris conscience et sont de plus
en plus engagé les grandes conférences
internationales que sont les coptes sont
certainement nécessaires pour impulser
une mobilisation mondiale et
sensibiliser les états mais il faut que
les coop soit réellement utile et qu'il
en sort du concret la coop 25 de madrid
la coop la plus longue de l'histoire est
apparu comme déconnecté par rapport aux
demandes d'actions exprimer les
résultats sont consternantes ans ils
sont faibles
les négociateurs n'ont pas pu s'entendre
sur les règles d'application de l'accord
de paris sur la question clé du marché
carbone
aucun état ne s'est engagé pour
participer au fonds vert
la question des pertes et préjudice à
savoir les destructions déjà
irréversibles liée au réchauffement
notamment en afrique avec la création
d'un fond a échoué
ce n'est pas possible on risque de
décrédibiliser définitivement les
sommets internationaux
cette coop avait besoin de leadership
politique ou a été le leadership
français très fort sur le climat en avec
la coop 21 quel rôle a joué
l'exécutif français dans cette coque 25
pour vous répondre la parole qu'aux
bonhomme dargaud en tracteur d'état